being able to work on group projects
being able to practice role plays with
my classmates being able to provide and
receive direct feedback all these
require me to work with other people all
these require me to get outside my
comfort zone and learn and stretch and
girl being a student in my classrooms
that the GSB is not a spectator sport
the notion is that depending on the kind
of class we have the instructor and the
goals that they pick the pedagogy that
works best for them professor Krause
Bagwell who is a serious entrepreneur
founded 515 companies in his life
role-playing with him how to fire and
hire people being respectful but still
direct amazing experience I had if
you're learning something which is more
hardcore you really need a lecture based
approach to kind of soak in the
information I teach a class in North
Core which we call foundations on
management accounting given the nature
of the material much of what I do is
lecture and then you have all these
projects where you apply this
information very very transformational
idea that came across in the lecture
that I really value feedback is one of
the core components of the Stanford GSB
experience and you're hit with it really
from day one when this situation
occurred here's how you reacted and
here's how that came off and then you
receive feedback on how the feedback you
gave landed what that allowed me to do
was go back and fix those specific
behaviors so as you think about becoming
a manager someday that's really
important too
how your feedback comes across from the
global side trip I think the one thing
I'll never forget is probably meeting
the sitting president of Rwanda Paul
Kagame the man is credited for ending
the genocide the interplay between the
two of them the back and forth and
sometimes hearing the different
perspectives was hugely helpful in
informing how I think about business
what I want to do who I want to be and I
want to react the one thing the GSB
stresses is that we don't want to be
wedded to any one particular method but
in far my best experience was a
simulation of the UN with Professor
Condoleezza Rice as part of her global
class what was about the European crisis
we actually represented Russia I am
being from Germany had to play Greece
against Germany 48 hours later
represented to the former secretary of
the state was just it was amazing if
you're gonna learn how to exercise
judgment in the context of complex
situation to me cases is the best way to
do it
what might you do to
we use the case as a platform to
roleplay and and just discuss management
issues and that is so helpful because
they bring the context the situation the
milieu that the case was actually
involved in and that's something that's
missing in just case heart fat and
though we might have studied the case
before with the best solution in mind
once we got there and saw the facts on
the ground the reality was much when I
was accepted at Stanford than one of the
first things I did was figure out how I
could get into extreme affordability so
we come in and we actually take all
these different ideas and when one idea
comes in that's very eccentric or wild
and loud
it actually Spurs an idea that's real
more acceptable and meaningful the rest
of these are really nice solutions to
echo problems but that one kind of like
and then pretty soon we find ourselves
going down this path together even
though we're from various different
backgrounds to solve this common need I
think it's really opened my eyes to some
of the interesting insights that can
come out of you know students from the
law school students from the medical
school it's been fantastic the students
are always getting cutting-edge
knowledge there are always classes being
taught here that would never be taught
anywhere else because no one else is
even thinking about the application of
what we're doing to business I wish I
could take all the knowledge I've worked
in the last year and a half have that
with me and go back and do this
experience all over again
there is no question it's more engaging